hey guys and welcome to let's play City
skylines this is a game that came out
today and I've been waiting for the
release of this game for a very long
time and I'm so happy to have it right
now so I'm going to do a small
introduction of about 40 seconds
explaining what I'm going to do and how
I'm going to do that and why because
this game if you don't know it it's made
by paradox and it's kind of like SimCity
except it's a lot better and it's pretty
much the SimCity we've always wanted to
have but never had now my let's play is
going to be a bit different from many of
the other ones out there because I'm
going to do a similar thing to what I'm
doing - Rocco's taken three helmets
actually it's the exact same thing I'm
going to record for about two hours each
time and turn it into a time-lapse and
then do the commentary over that because
this is going to be much more about
actually seeing the city progress and
making cool cities and stuff like that
then about the actual gameplay and
actually getting to know what I'm
thinking about one doing the cities and
yeah that's basically what I'm going for
is so nice cities rather than nice
gameplay I suppose that's a good way to
put it now as you might see here I'm
already getting started so the thing
that I had in mind was you need a good
kind of Road layout so that's the basic
well thing of a city if you don't have a
great road layout I suppose it's really
hard to actually turn into great city
now the thing is there are many ways to
do with this but I decided to just go
for a kind of suburb but also kind of
Dutch thingy because I don't know why
people do that over here but for some
reason although it roads over here or
all twisted and crooked so I decided to
do that because it just seemed natural
to me and yeah one thing I probably
should say though is that I'm totally
crazy about trees at this point I was
just like okay we're gonna build many
houses loads of things we're gonna get
to that
certain population number so we can
build trees and then we're going to make
an amazing city so this is really just
the beginning and as you can see the
main idea that I had in mind over here
was I'm going to have that main kind of
Avenue running through the town and then
I'm going to have the very small roads
over there which go in all their correct
ways and are actually not all that
efficient but surprisingly none of them
are actually stuck right now or there's
no traffic jams or anything
I mean in still small town but you know
I was somewhat surprised by that and
yeah I'm just going to put all the
commercial stuff around the big roads
and all the houses along the small curvy
roads and I don't know if that's an
entirely realistic thing for everyone
but that's just the kind of thing that I
earn in mind and I might always change
this later on when the land value gets
higher or I get higher buildings at
office buildings but this is for now the
kind of sub urban city that I'm going to
create at the moment and of course I'm
going to build loads of parks and stuff
with that as well and as you can see
it's growing pretty quickly or at least
it seems to be growing pretty quickly
this is about the work of ten minutes
that were in right now and especially
because you have so much money to start
off with it's pretty fast and that's
something that I've really noticed about
this game it's the fact that it's
incredibly easy really because I spent
the last couple of days just looking at
videos studying everything about this
game which did two things I mean for one
it taught me many things about the game
but many of those things were already
and pretty similar to me because it's so
similar to SimCity that you probably if
you have a lot of SimCity experience
you're going to get this game right away
and I can tell from experience that
that's definitely going to happen but
that's not the only thing because
looking at all those videos just made me
want to make this when to play this game
so much more but yeah what I really
noticed about things about this game is
that it's so easy but then again it's
it's fun and it's really hard because
normally you'd have to find the balance
between an easy game and a hard game
actually giving the player a challenge
in order for it to be fun but I found
out that at least for me it was so much
fun in this game to actually get the
city to thrive even if it was very easy
and even if the if the game was taking
me through all these baby steps it was
just so great to see the city grow like
it is right now as you can see and at
this point I got the trees so as you
might be able to see I kind of got a
green thumb over there and decided to
place trees everywhere I was kind of sad
to see that you can place trees next to
industrial zones or otherwise they're
going going to be dead and stuff like
that and the ground is still purple
on the industrial zones I've heard that
they might change that in the future at
some point into a more greyish kind of
texture but at the moment it's purple
which is kind of weird but other than
that you know it's really cool and the
graphics are really amazing in this game
too and at this point I was like okay we
need to cross the bridge because I was
pretty much out of room over there on
one and one side I had of course the
town and on the other side had the
industrial zone which was polluted as
hell which was not really the greatest
thing so I decided to go over to the
other edge of the river and see what I
could do over there it's almost it's
almost turning into like a suburb of a
suburb kind of thing and you could see
me placing all the water pipes over
there and that's also one thing it like
I keep noticing all of these things that
you have in Sim City - except there they
have been improved in this game and it's
just minor things in the game that I
really like about things and well wow
that was very vague it's just these
minor points that I like about games for
example if you place the water pipes you
can see which area they're going to
affect if you place roads you can see
which area you can zone and how many
roads you're going to have to place to
get a certain area of zoned land and
that's very awesome very handy but it
also looks very good so I'm really happy
about that and as you can see the
graphics are of course amazing
very colorful in a sense and I've never
been a fan of cartoony graphics but this
just seems to work somehow and this is
also something that I'm really happy
about the the way the buses work over
here because I never imagined that I I
was never really a kind of buzz freak in
my entire life but when I got to that
option I was like oh it is actually lots
of fun to place all of these bus routes
and you know see where you can take your
people and how what's the best way to
get them to that work in the industrial
zone over there I don't know if this is
actually really a great kind of way to
do all that but I suppose that I can
take my experience from SimCity that if
you don't have buses and trains leading
to your industrial zones you can have
terrible terrible traffic jams so I
definitely wanted to avoid that in this
case and I'm pretty sure that with
stuff like that this game pretty much
functions in the same way that SimCity
does and at this point I think everybody
died because yeah I think that yeah and
that was it because I didn't have the
cemetery yet and like all my old people
were dying and I didn't have anywhere to
burry them so there were dead people
everywhere and that's when the city kind
of got bad and at some point but that's
also something that you often have in
SimCity no just these moments where you
you just forget about one thing it's
either water or electricity or garbage
and your entire city just turns into a
mess for a couple of seconds and then
the game notifies you and you're like oh
wait I need to do something and then
it's all okay again and I got the
windmills which is which is really
really cool like I really love that if
you're a kind of green person you can do
whatever you want without hurting the
environment too much of course there's
the industrial zones which are kind of
terrible in that sense but it's it's the
most efficient way funnily enough in
this game so you get energy is with
windmills which are more efficient than
coal power plants depends on which place
you place them now because certain
places are windier than others and that
actually affects the amount of power
that a windmill generates which is just
one of those other neat little details
that I love about this game so far and
then there's a music though seriously
that music is amazing and yeah at this
point I was trying to make the
industrial zone bigger because there was
so much demand for industry and at some
point I made it bigger and then suddenly
the amount just dropped and all of the
industry got abandoned yeah stuff like
that happens sometimes I'm not really
sure how that happened but so far I
haven't had really had too many problems
with zoning or anything like that so
definitely not too hard or complicated
in that sense and I still had that power
in line running through my city even
though it was extremely unnecessary
because there were already buildings
everywhere and stuff like that and
really glad that you don't have to
actually lay all the underground
electricity cables yourself and at this
point I was like okay I'm pretty glad
about the way that I've met the city but
I definitely want to make this race and
this is the kind of thing and like that
you're Harmon Bullock coaster tycoon
when naming your attractions or maybe
you're a Pokemon and more Pokemon of
course but for me that's just one of the
fun games one of the fun things in games
when you can name things I don't know
it's just it's just great so I decided
to create some districts and give them
terrible names i name them after
real-life cities so it's not really
anything very unique or original in that
sense not very creative but you know
it's handy having those districts and
you can actually see loads of
information you can see the general kind
of jobs that people are doing the
education that they get and it's really
awesome to see not just information on
your city but actually being able to
divide the information and see what kind
witness statistics for a certain places
within your city and the options in this
game so far seem endless and that is
really awesome not to mention the fact
that it's going to have much support and
I'm pretty sure there are already many
mods out there for if you really want to
model this game I mean know plenty of
people who are into that so yeah this
was it for the first episode of City
skylines it went really fast and I must
say I am incredibly impressed so far
it's definitely an amazing game it's
definitely everything I've ever wanted
in Sim City but never had and I'm
already having more fun than I've ever
had in any SimCity game to be honest
it's really great it's easy but it's
still a fun there is loads of things to
explore in the game and there are so
many things that SimCity just did wrong
or you wished it had that I just find in
this game and I must get my compliments
on the music as well because I think
that music is one of the most important
factors actually in a game perhaps even
more important than graphics sometimes
because if you really want to delve into
the experience of a certain game the
music is so important in actually
getting you there and this music is so
inspiring but it's epic at the same time
and I thought I am not too sure about
this but I think I've noticed that when
certain buildings level up and stuff
like that you actually get different
music tracks so when you're just
starting out you get this slow easy
music and when you're building stuff and
your cities growing and it's getting big
and epic you also get this big and epic
music so that's really awesome and
overall I am so happy about this game
there aren't no there are not you know
minutes to actually say what I like
about this game so I suppose I'll have
to do that later on in the series but
I'm glad that I bought it I think you
should definitely buy it if you're into
city building and don't have it yet and
thanks for watching and see you in the
next episode